Elon Musk just addressed the G20. Here
it is.
>> Well, yeah.
I think a lot of people have talked
about this and I think some of it
frankly is is is pretty straightforward
is that
you you have to have an environment
that's relatively free of regulation.
Meaning that new things must be default
legal as opposed to default illegal.
Um
So,
in in the EU for example, we find that
there's the regulation level is
extraordinarily high and things are
generally default illegal.
Um and this inhibits
progress of new technologies.
It slows it down. It doesn't It doesn't
ultimately stop it, but it slows it down
quite considerably.
Um there of course you need to have um
a
you need to have venture capitalists
and an environment that is
supportive of new companies. You can
think of new companies like
little like they're like small saplings
in a forest.
So, what what most
countries tend to do is they tend to
provide too much support to the large
existing trees in the forest and not
enough to the small saplings.
But the large trees don't need the
support. It's the small saplings that
do, the startups.
And so, the system should be generally
biased towards supporting the small
the small trees as opposed to the larger
ones.
Um
but that is rarely the case.
Uh because the the large the the large
companies have access to
um
usually they have access to the
leadership of the countries.
And the small the the small startups do
not.
So, you So, you really need to foster
the the growth of of young companies and
take active steps in that regard.
Um
and like I said, make things default
legal, not default illegal.
>> What one question that um a lot of the
countries here face is a question around
adoption. I think there's a a general um
recognition that adopting emerging
technologies can be very beneficial to
economic growth um no matter what sort
of shape size of of of any country is.
Um you know, how how do you think about
adoption? What country What should
countries be doing to encourage
adoption? Does it go back to the same
sort of regulatory structures or or how
do you think about adoption as a as a
key driver for growth?
>> Yeah, I I I think you you want to have a
lean forward try new technologies
approach to new technologies. Otherwise,
as opposed to be somewhat stuck in the
past. Um
naturally, new technologies need need to
be need some encouragement and and uh
and I think should be embraced. Um
We are going to see and are seeing in
fact significant productivity gains from
artificial intelligence um and
and we'll see very dramatic gains in
productivity from robotics.
Um you know, things like the Tesla
self-driving car is going to be a
tremendous boon or is a tremendous
tremendous boon already um
to users.
Um
and and and I think humanoid robotics
will be just an incredible change. I I
think just to give you some sense of
scale here, I think the um
I I think AI will probably
increase the global
uh economy by 20 to 30%. That's my rough
rough estimate.
Um meaning on the order of 20 to 30
trillion dollars per year.
>> Yeah, over what
time frame? So, he's saying per year.
So, he thinks he thinks a 20 to 30%
boost on an annual basis. Let's Let's
rewind that for a moment.
>> global
uh economy by 20 to 30%. That's my rough
rough estimate.
Um meaning on the order of 20 to 30
trillion dollars per year.
>> Yeah, he's talking global.
>> And and AI will be able to do anything
digital and anything that does not
require shaping of atoms by hand.
Um probably by the end of next year.
So as as I'm sure people know
AI is already
uh incredibly good at software.
Um
and
it it's getting to the point where
AI won't just be good at software, it'll
be what I call Stockfish level good. So
Stockfish is a chess program that can
beat the world's best chess players very
easily.
In fact,
at this point you could run Stockfish on
your phone and beat Magnus Carlsen at
chess.
So uh
at some at some point next year is my
prediction.
Uh software will be so good AI software
will be so good that it will be
Stockfish level good, meaning that it is
impossible for a human to compete in
writing software uh with AI. But like AI
will just crush all humans at software.
And I think it'll it will be uh
extremely good
possibly
Stockfish level, but
but but certainly extremely good at all
forms of engineering and anything
digital. Uh literally
in 12 12 to 18 months.
>> All right, so let's just be clear about
what Elon is saying. He's not saying AI
will crush all software. He's saying AI
will crush software coding. That's at
least what I just gathered from that. He
says a human will not be able to compete
with writing code because AI code
generated software or software generated
by AI code essentially will be so good,
it'll be indistinguishable from
essentially master level chess players
uh or master level coders. And obviously
Elon is exceptionally bullish right here
on global gross domestic product,
suggesting that by the end of 2027,
global GDP, so everywhere, you know,
throughout any kind of country, uh could
potentially grow 20 to 30% annually.
Obviously, some of the GDP growth that
we're seeing in the United States,
which, you know, on Q3 data is running
hot, over 4% right now, based on just
current uh capital expenditures, mostly
artificial intelligence,
you know,
that's great. But, how much of that is
because of the circular spend that we
are seeing as opposed to real
productivity growth? Now, I think
there's productivity growth in
artificial intelligence, and we see
companies all the time referencing the
productivity growth happening without
inside of companies. But, at what point,
as companies have said, we were looking
at one of the Course Member live stream
this morning. Uh remember, we briefly
extended that coupon code due to the
glitch last Friday until this Friday. Uh
but, we were looking at a company this
morning, and they they warned, "Hey,
AI is good, but human-in-the-loop
[snorts]
artificial intelligence is better." They
make the argument that there's
deterministic
code or deterministic software, and that
there's generative software, a genetic
software. And the best solution isn't
only in on one or the other, it's
actually both. Human helping write the
deterministic solutions, use the
artificial intelligence where you can,
you don't get locked into a layer model,
uh and that reasonably competes with
human labor. Problem with that is if you
compete with human labor, at some point,
that actually has a risk of depressing
GDP potentially before it rises.
Uh that's obviously a downside risk.
>> I W- One of the stats
>> So, so, so,
actually, I'll Let me add just one one
more thing to that. My apologies. Um the
the So, 20 20 30% increase of total
global economy, so this is quite a lot
of prosperity we're talking about here.
Um
Uh just just digital AI, but from
robotics,
uh, from um
from humanoid, uh, basically think of
like a general purpose robot robot AI.
I think we'll see many multiples of the
global economy.
Meaning like you you can increase the
economy
by a factor of 10 or more.
The these are mind-boggling numbers.
>> Yeah, I was just about to say that I
mean [clears throat] one of the stats we
gave to the group here was that, um, in
the four years since sort of chat GPT
was launched, I think we there's, you
know, over a billion people around the
world already using AI. There's been
very quick uptake around around the
country on around the world on that. I
guess the question to you is I think a
lot of people think about sort of the
the next chapter being in this sort of
applied or or sort of physical AI. Where
where do you see sort of robotics
trending? How quickly is it going to be
implemented? I think I remember in the
first Trump administration we were
talking about sort of automated
factories and now we're a year later a
10 years later. So how how how, you
know, how quickly do you think these
these changes are happening in the sort
of physical AI world?
>> Yeah, so so anything physical always
takes longer than anything which is
digital. Digital, you know, it's it's
when when when you sell something
digitally it's the software that you can
easily copy across other other
computers.
Um
when it's physical you've got to build
up an entire massive supply chain.
You've got to you've got to move a lot
of lot of atoms. Um
all and and supply chains are very much
global at this point. So
uh, that's why it takes longer.
Nonetheless, um, when you think of
humanoid robotics, the way
the the way you think about it I
I think the right framework is consider
that the usefulness of a humanoid robot,
a general purpose robot, is going to be
um
roughly the, uh, digital
uh, the the the AI software how how how
good is the AI software times how good
is the, uh, AI chip in the robot times
how good is the electromechanical
dexterity, especially of the hands.
Um now all three of those things are
improving exponentially.
Um and and the usefulness of the robot
is those those three things multiplied
by each other. Then, when you make the
robots, the robots will um
um
the robots will start manufacturing the
robots. So, you get a recursive effect.
So, [laughter] it it's
>> Guys,
invest in Tesla because we're going to
get to fire all our employees
and the Optimus robots will manufacture
the Optimus robots.
Now, in fairness, that is going to be
the future. I actually don't think that
the
productivity per person is best served
in a factory. So, in fairness, I
actually in the long term agree with
Elon here. I think that vision is
probably 15 years out. I think really
the next the robotic revolution is This
is my opinion. Maybe I'm too far off. I
think the robotic revolution is probably
between 2036 to 2045. So, about 10 years
out and for the next 10 years. And maybe
towards the end of that chain, so like
2045, that's when robots are assembling
other robots. Uh
you know, may may maybe I'm too bearish
on that. It's going to happen. But,
generally,
uh the standard of living rises as you
move from a manufacturing economy to a
service-based economy. Think, for
example, uh if you look at uh you know,
Malaysia, Sri Lanka, China, uh the
average worker working in a factory is
unfortunately suffering uh well, maybe I
shouldn't say the average worker, but
many workers are suffering poor working
conditions and they're just doing
physical, basic, repetitive labor with
their hands that in the longer term
should all just be replaced by
machinery. And these are folks that
should be working in the service
industry. And as global wealth rises,
more people can spend on travel,
entertainment, hotels, you know,
whatever, airfare, busting, whatever it
is, that enables more of a sales-based
service industry, which rises the per
capita income of everybody in a region.
And and that's really where humans
should go. So, I know that sounds really
apocalyptic from Elon like, "Oh, they're
all going to get fired."
In the long term, it's actually a good
thing. I just think it's going to take
longer than than is typically projected.
>> It's also a very very slowly, but then
it grows
at an explosive rate. Um so, if you you
say like 10 years from now, I would say
there are well over a billion humanoid
robots.
>> Right. So,
my take is that is probably two to three
X too early. That's the Elon time frame.
What a great way to discount Tesla
stock, though. And when I say discount,
I mean underwrite, like it's a good
thing.
Uh you know, I mean, what you basically
just said. You just went You just went
to the G20, and you basically just did
Adam Jonas, underwrite Tesla 2036 at 1
billion robots. Exponential growth
curve. Work it back. Tell the world it
5X's the stock today.
>> [laughter]
>> It's kind of incredible. Uh Scott here
in the chat says, "I'm worried about my
child's future who's just starting
kindergarten to uh 15 to 20 years from
now."
Have no fear.
Have no fear. Every single generation of
humans
has made it.
>> [laughter]
>> Unless the sun goes out, your children
are going to be fine. Children are
highly adaptive. Humans are highly
adaptive. They're going to be okay. Do
not be afraid to have children. Have
children. I've got seven of them. I want
more. The best thing you can do is is
love them, make them good, honest,
hard-working people, and they will find
their way. Don't worry about technology.
>> Wow.
>> Um and the productivity per robot will
be probably five times that of a human.
Meaning Meaning that the productivity in
10 years of humanoid robots, and I think
this is a conservative estimate, by the
way.
Um
This is This is what I I I would would
not be willing to put to put serious
money betting on.
Um that there will be at least a billion
robots in 10 years, and that those
robots will be at least
>> In fairness, he is putting his money on
it with this exposure via Tesla stock,
right? So, like, all right.
>> at least five times the output of a
human. Meaning the the the billion
humanoid robots will will um
be more productive than all humans
combined.
>> Yeah, right. Because if if
Close. Because if you've got
you know, a billion robots five times
more productive, that's the equivalent
of about five billion humans.
Uh
We have more humans on Earth, but some
of them aren't productive because
they're children or they're elderly or
whatever, right? So, I I see the analogy
that he's making. Uh yes, in the long
term he's right. Humanoids will be more
productive at certain things uh than
humans, especially mechanical things.
Absolutely uh the future. Uh but uh
there is a limit to how much
productivity, ironically, that you need
at any given point. Like, I can only
have my floor mopped so much, right? So,
one of the bounds of even what
artificial intelligence can do for a
business is how fast is my business
growing? Yeah, it could enable me to
grow faster, but I still only have X
customer inbound emails. You know, if AI
makes me more productive at responding
to emails just as a simple example, and
I can respond to the 100 emails faster,
great. I could go work on growing the
business more. But if that grows to 110
emails, I still only have 110 emails to
deal with. It's the same thing on a
large scale with robotic purposes. If I
need to make
a million bricks a year, I or a day,
call it, for home construction,
we might not necessarily need that to be
5 million. It might need to go to 1.1.
Right? So, there is a curve that sort of
limits how productive you could actually
be. That ultimately leads to massive
cost deflation in the near term. So, if
you create so much productivity, you
actually lower the cost. And so,
actually what you're doing is creating
massive deflation. Now, of course,
expect central bankers in the future to
print that all away.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh but uh but yeah, I mean the the these
ultimately tends to be good for society
in the long term.
>> Wow. Um sh- shifting gears just a little
bit to to
to a question that's kind of facing the
US today.
>> Kevin, don't you think Elon's robots
will have the same fate as Tesla cars?
Uh that is, China wins? 100%.
I'm I'm 100% convinced that the the
ultimate way
to win in the robotics race is to
manufacture them in a place like China.
China or a place that has competitive
edges like that, potentially India,
right? That does not mean that Tesla
loses. Remember, Tesla started the EV
revolution in Shanghai, China.
>> [laughter]
>> So,
um
they will be manufactured most
efficiently in in a country like China
or India or something like that. Uh but
I think that Tesla can actually benefit
by manufacturing in those areas. Watch
Giga Shanghai end up turning into the
Optimus factory in the long term. It'll
happen.
>> Data centers have been uh a big
political issue over the over the last
um 6 to 8 months here in the United
States. And I think there's a a general
understanding that um in order to to
drive and power the the the AI
revolution that's coming, we need to
have the the electricity um and the data
center uh compute capacity um to to do
the training and the inference of of all
of this AI.
You know, how do you how do you think
about this particular issue?
Where where are we on the on the curve
of kind of how much we built versus
>> JOLTS just slightly missed, by the way.
Job openings came in at 4.4 versus 4.5.
I've got job open that's percent. Job
openings themselves numerically 7.271
million. Slight miss versus the 7.313
expected. About a two almost that's like
180,000 revision down from the prior
read. Quits level came in lower than
expected at 1.9% versus the 2% expected.
That matters because when fewer people
are quitting it's a suggestion that
people were worried maybe about the
labor market and their prospects for
getting a new job. Just small little
note there.
>> Well, there actually is a quite a crisis
of power.
So, the this is a
In fact, this is something if you if you
just if you're just sort of follow the
AI topic on the X platform
which by the way is is where almost all
of the AI discourse takes place. Um
I think you get a very good sense for
where things are headed. Um
That's how that's how I get my news and
it's it's incredibly good. Everyone
who's anyone in AI posts on X.
Um so so so that's why I'd recommend
like just just
just go on the AI AI AI topic on X and
you'll you'll understand all these these
things and get a day day by day account
of things. The the
And and and what the consensus is at
this point is that the there will be a
significant power shortfall
next year. So, not like distant future.
There's expected to be I believe I
believe the the consensus estimate among
analysts that follows the AI space very
closely is that there will be at least a
a 15 gigawatt
uh
of power
uh in 2027 for AI chips.
So,
this is the
>> and there's a big expectation that China
is crushing us in terms of power
development, potentially to the tune of
two x'ing how much power we are
developing, which which is pretty
remarkable.
Uh small little note here just in the
Meet Kevin wire, which you could
download uh for free as a
the Meet Kevin app in the Google or
Android app store. Look like uh here uh
GoPro shares up 60% after company to be
acquired in a $285 million deal. Well,
let's keep going with Elon here.
>> It's um
an obvious
thing that one would expect to occur
because
the rate at which AI chips is being
produced is is
has been rising incredibly rapidly.
They're sort of rising on the order of
40 to 50 40 to 50% a year. But the but
the power available outside of China has
been rising at like 10 to 20% a year.
So, obviously uh
the the faster rising thing will will
eventually overwhelm the slower rising
thing, and so um
in fact, even I'd say at this point,
there there there are challenges with
power even before next year, which is
why uh Google and Anthropic and many
other companies are actually leasing
compute from SpaceX
um because we've been able to turn on um
AI better than anyone else so far. And
but this is by by constructing our own
power plants.
It's the only way we were able to do it.
Um so, now now China does have a
tremendous amount of electricity, but
but
>> due to GPU export bans, one cannot uh
you know, establish data centers with
the latest chips in China. So, so as but
so really the consideration is what what
sort of electricity growth is there
outside of China.
Um and that is is currently a
significant shortfall relative to AI
chip production.
So there is this this creates an
opportunity I think for countries around
the world just to to save
to to to sort of if they're interested
in AI data centers um
to to to construct a lot of power um
and and offer that to
AI companies
and in exchange of course these data
centers would be would be taxed and and
have to pay you know reasonable fees and
stuff uh but
>> Well I and that's normal like a
corporation that exists inside of a
sovereign is going to pay taxes for the
earnings of that area.
Keep in mind data centers have very very
few humans in them. Like a data center
can operate with like 50 people compared
to an automotive plant of a similar
square footage you might have thousands
of people or even like the TSMC in
Arizona you get thousands of workers.
Data centers are great for temporary
jobs, construction jobs, horrible for
permanent jobs. This is one of the
political issues that people have with
data centers. Obviously if we can create
disinflation in artificial intelligence
which eventually sort of trickle-down
economics across the the whole economy,
great. But a lot of people you know
don't believe in that linkage.
>> It does create an opportunity for for a
lot of countries.
>> Absolutely. Well thank you so much for
your time. It means a lot that you could
join us here and really appreciate it.
>> Any final words?
>> You're most welcome. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah I mean that that's really
interesting. So
if I put together I mean really Elon
kind of left them speechless there with
his projections. You kind of had a yeah
I hear hear the person in the background
like wow.
Oh man.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh
look I'm a fan of the long-term vision.
I think his expectations almost have to
be
two to three x ludicrous
in terms of time frame because it sort
of motivates the whole race now. So to
some extent the time frame delusionalism
that Elon Musk creates actually helps
foster the very industry to go
delusional on electric vehicles brought
us to the EV revolution we had which has
somewhat started to unwind because of
preferences and partly potentially
because of Trump and tax credits for
EVs. There's also frustration over range
anxiety versus man it's just so nice to
just
fill up your car. Like there's no worse
place to get exposed to an electric
vehicle in my opinion than renting a car
somewhere and somebody's like you should
have an electric car and I'm like in a
foreign country you expect me to go find
chargers and wait let me guess
you want me to top it off before I
return the car.
>> [laughter]
>> And then you sit somewhere for two hours
to fill it up or like there's some
frustrations with that. But the point is
his grandeur around
this infrastructure sort of led to the
EV boom and and now
you know that that ended up driving in a
full self-driving revolution. Now it's
driving a space revolution
to some extent a computer revolution
with how rapidly we could potentially
deploy. So there's there's a lot in his
time frames that yeah he misses but it's
almost almost like you have to be
somewhat time frame delusional to
eventually be right.
>> [laughter]
>> So it it is an interesting way to think
about Elon Musk [music] as an investor.
You sort of have to discount the time
frames but the trajectory is probably
accurate [music]
and
it's it's quite interesting. I liked it.
>> Why not advertise these things that you
told us here? I feel like nobody else
knows about this.
>> We'll we'll try a little advertising and
see how it goes.
>> Congratulations man you have done so
much. People love you people look up to
you.
>> Kevin Paffrath there financial analyst
and YouTuber Meet Kevin. Always great to
get your take.